a 77-year-old man named Kenneth
Darlington who's apparently an American
lawyer he has dual citizenship he
approached the blockade got out of his
car and then he shot two of the climate
protesters and killed
them now there are a bunch of news
reports describing Kenneth darlington's
actions as horrific and quote unquote
shocking that's not really true yes he
did gun down to Eco protesters but
there's nothing shocking about it if
you've been paying attention now what he
did is obviously wrong it's murder plain
and simple cannot be condoned but
shocking No in fact the only thing
really surprising about Kenneth
darlington's reaction is that he's the
first person to react this way in the
face of a completely unreasonable
sustained blockade of a road that
thousands of people depend on for their
livelihoods